اوروبا في نقطه فاصله في حرب اوكرانيا
ويجب توفير مزيدا من الاسلحه الكياب
ودبابات قتاليه هكذا يقول حلف شمال
الاطلسي وهو يسارع الخوطه لاستماع لوزراء
الدفاع في الحلف يوم الجمعه المقبل في
قاعده اينشتاين الجويه في المانيا
واصد ذلك ترددت كلمه الدبابات كثيرا فهي
التي بموسوعها ان تحدث فرقا على الارض
وتركيز تصريحا وتلميحا بدم صبا على
المانيا وتحديدا على الدبابات اليوبارد
اثنين ويحتاج الامر الى موافقه برلين
لارسالها
فيستو تحدث عن حاجتك للدبابات في لقاء خاص
للجزيره على هامشي منتدى ذا فويس
الى دبابات وهناك مشاورات مع المانيا قلنا
ان لدينا في مخزناتنا دباباته ليوبارد
اثنان وطبعا المانيا وبولندا ستقدمان
اعدادا اكبر لكن يمكن ان نساعد نحن ايضا
من خلال الصيانه والتدريب على الدبابات
تعد دبابات وليوبارد اثنين الالمانيه
الموجوده في نحو 20 دوله من افضل
المجنزرات في الغرب تعتبر من دبابات
القتال الرئيسيه وتبلغ سرعتها القصوى نحو
70 كيلومترا في الساعه تزن الدبابه
الواحده اكثر من 60 طن وهي مزوده بمدفع من
عيار 120 ملمترا ويمكنها اصابه الاهداف
على مسافه تصل الى خمس كيلومترات وتوصف
بانها المزيج المثالي من الحمايه والتنقل
والقدره على المناوره والقوه الناريه
الى استخدام الدبابات القتال الرئيسيه
الالمانيه الصنع وحدث حلفائها قائله
ارسلوا الدباباتكم الى اوكرانيا الان حتى
لا تضطر الى التعامل مع الدبابات الروسيه
في وقت لاحق تزويد اوكرانيا بمنظمات
الدفاع الجوي يجب ان يكون اسرع منها هجمات
روسيا الصاروخيه القادمه تزويدنا
بالدبابات الغربيه يجب ان يكون اسرع من اي
هجوم روسي جديد وقد تكونوا تطورات الاخيره
خصوصا في الجبهه الشرقيه شكلت عامل ضغط
رئيس المجلس
الاوروبيات في وجه ما وصفها باستراتيجيه
تدمير وارهاب تنتهي في حربها على اوكرانيا
بولندا اعلنت انها سترسل السريه دبابات من
نوع اليوبارد اثنين الى اوكرانيا وحدث
بريطانيا احد وفرنسا وبولندا بتعاهد
بتقديم المزيد من الاسلحه بين هدبابات
قتاليه بينما قالت اسبانيا ان تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات غير مطروح حاليا حاله
الاستضاف الاوروبيه بمعيه الولايات
المتحده دفعت وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
الاتهام واشنطن بتشكيل تحالف ضد روسيا
يشبه ممارسات الزعيم النازي ادولف هتلر ضد
الاتحاد السوفيتي بينما قال الرئيس الروسي
انه يثق بالنصر في الحرب انطلاقا من
النتيجه النهائيه والنصر الحتمي هناك امور
القادمه
اسلحه الغربيه والدبابات الالمانيه ضروريه
للبقاء على قيد الحياه